so i'm looking for people who have known
each other for a while
uh and preferably with some experience
of
working together because they're going
to be working together now for a few
years
and they need to get along together um
i'm looking for
at least one team member which is a an
exceptional talent in in
in something welcome to 20-minute
leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc found in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomi tech and
sponsored by hippo
insurance touring opposed labs and
hillel at stanford
what drives a three-time entrepreneur
and serial
investor in top companies to continue
doing what he's doing
meet leron rose founder and ceo of rose
innovation
lyron is a three-time entrepreneur and
investor with several unicorn exits in
tel aviv's thriving tech scene
his latest startup after download was
acquired by ironsource after three years
he later launched and managed barclays
bank accelerator with tech stars in
israel
lyron enjoys fostering israel's
brightest entrepreneurs in their quest
for vision and leadership
together with a group of hnwi family
offices
investment banks and venture capital
investments include iron source
fiverr armis similar web and many many
more
lyron rose welcome to 20 minute leaders
i'm honored to have you here how are you
great michael thanks for having me
honored to be here
with you too no no thank you for coming
here i know how busy you are and
i'm gonna try to be very selfish here
and extract as much
knowledge as i can from you in these 20
minutes this is my goal
and i'll measure my kpi in about 19
minutes or so
so i think we'll just get started on
you're one of israel's most prominent
investors having invested in some of the
most thank you incredible
incredible companies that that i can
think of the list
goes on and on from almost to fiverr to
island source
it's a similar web and what these have
in common besides the fact that they're
just fantastic fantastic companies
these are uh invented investments that
we've also done pretty early and i think
that one of the
magic that i'll try to extract from is
this identifying
these real winners so early on when a
lot of it is sometimes based on
intuition and
you don't have much data to base it on
but even before we go that levon
tell me a little bit of who you are how
do you consider yourself
are you an investor are you an
entrepreneur who are you
i would say uh investorpreneur so i'm
both
an investor and entrepreneur i was i was
a startup founder for uh for a couple of
a couple of times
my latest company was acquired by iron
source a few years ago
and i also established
the tech stars accelerator right here in
israel and ran it for two years so i've
had the experience with the uh
interviewing
and reviewing hundreds of fintech
startups
and accepting 20 of them into my program
wow so
i've i've done a lot of startup due
diligence probably
thousands of companies invested in about
i would say two dozen companies beside
beside that the accelerator i mean and
yes as you
as you said a few of them have become
unicorns so
i think my hit rate is i'm pretty happy
with uh with the results so far
so so now my job is to take this hit
rate and and try to extrapolate
what what are what are some of the sub
components that that might make sense as
we think about unicorns we think about
you know joining teams early obviously a
lot of it is about the team about
product market fit
about the product but at the end you
know there's there's infinite
feasing the investment theses uh very
few
get to the place that you're at with
your track record so
i'd love to hear you know first
generally
how do you even approach this investment
idea
how do you approach this whole world of
investing your role in it
and and what you're actually trying to
do
okay so so first of all this is uh uh
the way i approach investments it
evolves
uh with time so the way i i
look at it now is not the same how i
look at it 10 or 15 years ago so it
changes
as as life i say as you
you know grow older and and life goes on
so so these days
for me startups and private equity in
general is
is one component of a larger portfolio
which
includes other assets as well like real
estate and
stock market public companies
investments but when i started
it was not like this so i i started as a
as an entrepreneur in online marketing i
was founder of a couple of companies
in online marketing and my the first
investments that i made
uh as an angel investor early stage
investments
were related to to that field so i think
uh point number one is uh
the more you are a domain expert the
more you are
familiar with the area of
you know the company the problems and
the solutions that the company
is trying to solve the more hands-on you
are the better the chances so i've had
two companies uh very early
investments uh uh from over 10 years ago
that have matured and become big
successes companies that
employ more than 500 600 people each
and those are related to my activities
my hands-on activities in online
marketing i was doing search engine
marketing
and affiliate marketing for many years
um
and some of the investments came from
from that area
amazing do you have you know in your
mind if i ask you to look back and think
of you know the most exciting
or weird moments as an investor is was
there a moment where you were sitting
with an early stage team
that you're in you're looking at them
and you're saying like i
i believe i know this is going to work i
believe in these guys and obviously you
believe in all the investments you made
otherwise you wouldn't have made them
but is there a specific example you can
they can share with me
when you're sitting with the team and
you're saying like wow like
these people are amazing
well i hope that my latest the latest
investment that i've made
just you know a few weeks
back will be like this because i've er
i was very enthusiastic about about the
team and about what they're
doing which is uh a artificial
intelligence art
and which is something that is a very um
very trendy now with the non-fungible
tokens and so forth so
i was very enthusiastic i was thinking i
thought the the the ceo was extremely uh
bright and talented and it was kind of a
no-brainer and this was
after i have i think it was
my first uh early stage investments
in in 12 months so i haven't invested in
anything for a year
and all of a sudden this deal came and
you know it's not that i haven't
you know seen hundreds of startups
during the 2020 but i haven't invested
so
as long as um when the the right deal
came um
it was pretty obvious that uh that they
are what does that mean
how do you what is the key
differentiator there what what is that
you know light switch
is it the fact that you really were
taken by the founder
was the problem more interesting than
others what what what did it for you
i think it's it's a collection of of a
few things right so
yes it is the team and and the the you
know noticing that the the
the ceo is is is extremely isn't what we
call an outlier so like two or three
standard deviations from from the mean
uh both in technical capabilities in
that case and
as well as managerial capabilities and
it's also a fact that um
that these guys already have traction
and have online sales
and and it is a it is an e-commerce
startup it has an ai component but it's
uh
ultimately an e-commerce venture and
this is a
with conversions and online marketing
which is something that i'm familiar
with so
i have a better ability to to gauge uh
where they are right and uh hope to see
the results
i love it enough they said that i i
actually did a i believe that i did an
episode
just a few days ago with the chief
marketing officer
of the company that you're talking about
and they are
and i actually happened to do research
on them for one of my stanford classes
which is why i reached out to them also
and they are it is a just mind-blowing
you know where
the world is headed and so obviously you
know i'll let you disclose it at your
own time
the company but i just have to say that
i think that it's it's it's extremely
exciting
but going back to some of these
components you mentioned that it's a
collection of components you know
collectively you piece together
these these different matrix that at the
end have to amount to
a beautiful partnership where you
believe solely but let's break it down a
little bit
what in your in your mind from your
experience what is sort of a key
differentiator in the team
perspective that you're saying this is
an example of a team that will win
versus a team that while on paper they
may look good
i'm not quite sure
so you you you phrased it correctly you
can never be sure and you know even if
all the components are there the the
startup can still fail right
but to answer your question uh when when
a team
goes into an expedition
uh of launching a startup we're looking
at anything between seven to
ten years uh of this mission
right and these people need to be able
to work together
and and stay together and stick together
because
this is a this is a roller coaster uh
journey and basically they're getting
married to each other for uh for
quite a long time so i'm prefer
well i usually prefer teams of two or
three founders
and it's better not to be a single
founder it's also
not so good to be more than three
founders because
then the team dynamics change um
so i'm looking for people who have known
each other for a while
uh and preferably with some experience
of uh
working together because they're going
to be working together now for a few
years
and they need to get along together um
i'm looking for
uh at least one team member uh which is
a
a exceptional talent in in in
in something so it could be a technical
ability it could be a creative ability
it could be
analytical capability but something
which is um
way out of the of the normal and out of
domain so you know you need
you need every team needs a winning team
needs a michael jordan like one michael
jordan
is enough we don't need two of them
because maybe then they will start to
compete right
all right on the yeah the ego the egos
will surface but if you have one of them
and the team knows who the michael
jordan is then you're in a good shape
how hard is it we're looking to how hard
is it to know
whether you have a michael jordan or not
is it fast or is it
you know a lot of reference checks a lot
of due diligence
um i would say something in the middle
um
so so you're looking at at the data
you're looking for data points who prove
that this
person is uh is it has some kind of an
excellent scene in
in in one or more things right so so you
could look at
their if we're in israel so we could
look at their military service and if
they have
right um a track record there from
one of those um technological units like
200 or one of the others or if or if
they're not technical then it could be a
one of the special forces
units uh anything like um
uh a leadership or or a field commander
this is or or a pilot uh
these kind of people who have uh
excelled in their military service
um it could be also in the uh in their
uh
university college academia so if they
have magna laude or a very high
grade whatever
something which is not so easy to
achieve
or it could be uh in sports right if
they they've
they've been uh you know swimmers uh
right people who can swim
uh you know five kilometers every day
and they've been doing that since they
they were 12 and they've
and you know i'm not even talking about
people who have competed
in the olympics but you get the idea
yeah yeah so
so this kind of or team players if it's
in basketball or
or or any other uh
sports these kind of things right
i think that you know looking at
obviously we can talk for hours about
all the different sub components at the
end we're still not going to come up
with
with an interesting enough investment
thesis that will hold
true for all circumstances right there's
there's infinite circumstances that uh
that are beyond
what what an investor can can perform in
a due diligence process but i think you
know touching on the idea of
of long-term partnerships and trying to
distill for how to we
again it's all about mitigating the risk
right what are the biggest reason why
starts fail and let's start going
through them and
trying to mitigate them and i think that
that's um
you know what i love about the this
field is that it just it's a it's a
complete unknown it's the most exciting
and there's a lot of surprises but at
the end there is
some some some patterns that that that
come up often
and so absolutely absolutely there's a
reason why the same nine people reach
the final
table of the world series of poker every
year and there's a reason why
the best investors invest in the best
companies it's
that it makes sense today
you mentioned that you're very
passionate also about about fintech and
you're
in about trust and bitcoin and and the
whole
way the world is shifting to that to
that place uh
while it it's a big buzzword and there's
a lot of hype around it i think that
the you know the fundamental
understanding of how
these different trust mechanisms are
going to change
consumer behavior and trust and change
the ecosystem as a whole
that's still very underestimated and
undervalued so share with me a little
bit about your thoughts
for what's happening and why you're
specifically excited about this path
right so so let me say this new unicorns
are being born uh when when new markets
uh and are are being born and
and when when you have disruptive uh
disruptive innovation and pioneering
technology something which is completely
new so
blockchain and bitcoin is uh
is is well it's not completely new we've
been we've been in this for the last 10
or 12 years but
fintech financial technology or finance
in general
is very uh it's a very uh conservative
and traditional
uh traditional vertical
as i said i ran i ran a fintech
accelerator for uh for
a bank for for a couple of years and
we've been interviewing hundreds of
startups and and
after uh i
finished running this operation i was
thinking you know
in within fintech what is the most
disruptive
uh out of the box uh theme
and i think it is it is blockchain
and i've uh i'm not the
you know i'm not the the first person to
identify
uh unfortunately bitcoin some people
have acquired bitcoins in 2012.
um i noticed this vertical
uh quite early but entered
uh around 2016
and and and the what i see now
is a few um a few uh developments
that um that uh
make me think that this is a huge
uh still a huge opportunity and we're
going to see
this uh field growing even further so
the way i look at it now
is i i say bitcoin and specifically
bitcoin and probably ether as well but
i'm sticking to this too because that's
about 90
of the entire market cap in in crypto
so bitcoin is probably the the biggest
disruption in
in savings in savings technology and
value conservation
interest since i would say a few decades
it's the first time we have and you know
we can we can open this discussion and
talk about this for hours
uh we don't have the time unfortunately
but uh
you have this money this new kind of
money which is fully digital
currency of the internet supply is
limited right and it's known so
so the supply is limited it's backed by
energy
it's backed by electricity so to produce
one bitcoin you need
so many uh kilowatt per kilowatt hours
of electricity
uh so it's backed like gold by
by physical scarcity so to speak
and what we see now is corporate america
uh
which was uh kind of on staff on the
sidelines
uh uh with this for a few years they
were
uh you know the sec did not approve it
and other regulators
right but in the last in the last
three to six months i would say we see
big corporations it started with a
company called microstrategy
who put placed
its entire treasury so wow i think 500
million dollars of
cash into bitcoin and then they borrowed
i think it was two billion dollars they
borrowed two billion dollars
zero interest on zero interest terms
and invested that into a bitcoin as well
and then tesla did this right
yes and then tesla did the same and and
and
what we see is more and more of these
corporations uh
going into this and it is a kind of a
financial hedge right they're seeing
uh and we just saw congress approving
another two trillion yes
uh dollar package uh yesterday
so we see it's a inflation expectations
of inflation
uh going up being regulated by
individuals
right and what these corporations are
doing
is you know they're saying look we're
not we don't know
what's going on with printing of money
let's uh do this asymmetric
a bet and place a few of our
a few percent you know not everyone
needs to be microstrategy right
but they can do five percent of the
treasury
and if that happens then uh
yeah this is just the start and and this
this thing also has an israeli angle
where we're
in israel here so we see a lot of
activity uh in the local scene
blockchain companies which been been
running uh
for a while the first i think we've seen
an acquisition this week of
curve yep by paypal for i think it was
two or three hundred million dollars
um we have we have a pretty significant
player
in the d5 decentralized finance field uh
celsius
that's another israeli company pretty
significant
um and we are also
uh in terms of well it's not israel but
in terms of ipo we're expecting a coin
based
ipo incredible 100 billion dollar ipo
soon
uh so i think this is uh something
that's
very exciting we see uh institutions
pouring into this asset class for
various reasons
uh and personally i think uh we're just
uh we just started i i think that you
know the big takeaway that i'm getting
from this and i've been hearing it again
in quite a few episodes now the big
takeaway from me is just i have to
understand it better
it's a new world it's a new you know i i
love
you know snowball effect i love
butterfly effect and
and you know while here we're talking
about the scope of yes that you know
we're talking about you know this is a
single change in the in
in the financial industry but that's not
a single change in the financial
industry it has
you know it has ricocheted effects in
literally every
everything in life from small business
owners to the way that consumers
consumer behavior is to spending
behavior
and it's and and i think that we've yet
to even begin to think about how this is
going to change our world
and and the pioneers like you that are
that are thinking critically about the
types of companies that are going to be
leading this the types of technologies
that are relevant
you know the rest of the world is gonna
you know follow in the footsteps of of
the
of the foundation that you're creating
so i think it's uh
it's something that i definitely want to
look more into
20 minutes go by way way too fast first
i want to
it's unbelievable i can't even fathom it
every single time but i
i really appreciate you coming here and
giving me your time it was phenomenal
i have one last important question for
you which is
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
so i would say down to earth
good communicator and data driven
i love it
best of luck with all the investments
and look out for a slide deck from me in
about a year or so
and until then stay safe and stay
healthy
thank you michael thanks for having me
appreciate it and
looking forward to speaking to you soon
have a great day